how do you break down your day how do
you schedule it you do have time set
aside for work whether it's related to
acting your screen writing and then
pursuing what you love to do I try to
work out in the morning but that's not I
don't I don't have I have found that
that there are squirrels in the cheese
time I found that I write best straight
out of it like when I wake up and it
might be you know whatever time it is
that if I write for like the first three
hours of the day or longer that I tend
to just be really focused and fresh I
guess so
sometimes I will write first thing in
the morning I don't know I change it up
because sometimes I like if I'm writing
I kind of like to write all day I kind
of like to get in his own and not be
interrupted by any other concerns but
that's hard if you have an audition you
can't do that or
if you have something else that's a
mobile you can't do that so I like to
block out an entire date right it's not
always practical though but I like the
freedom of knowing that and just let the
creative process happen and in its own
time and that tends to work well for me
in terms of you know pursuing acting
though I like to do that in the morning
- I think I like to put the bulk of my
day in the morning and then take the
afternoon or the evening off it's
usually I will try and work the entire
day on acting or writing or both squeeze
in writing if I've had an acting day and
then and then just take the night off
and have have whatever fun I'm going to
you know but but I don't know I don't I
don't have like a clockwork thing like
at 9:00 a.m. every morning this happens
and I've heard that other writers
specifically do like they'll keep
bankers hours or something I do keep
bankers hours or longer but that's like
the the one thing that's that's set if
I'm if I feel like I want to write first
thing tomorrow morning and write for
four hours I'll have to work out later
in the day and I'll just make
modifications for that I think
you have to do what your what your body
feels is right like if you write best
from 2:00 in the morning to 7:00 in the
morning I don't know when you'll sleep
but you have to listen to that to some
extent so I kind of play that by ear a
little bit but I do cut out time to work
every day
that's regimented how do you guard your
time though you say if you're if you're
getting a whole day of writing done are
there tricks or are there things that
you do to make sure that your errands
are done even before and then you can
precious cigar sure like if I'm working
a day job at the time I will not make
plans on a Saturday night
I will deliberately you know and
sometimes it's great because nothing
comes up on a Saturday night and you
don't have to say no but but I would
typically carve out an entire day and
not make plans with with anyone if
that's all I could afford myself which
at various times in my life that has
been the case is like if you have a job
like that like wouldn't you're supposed
to do it and I've heard like remember
hearing Kevin Williamson would get up
and work from like 4:00 in the morning
until 7:00 in the morning and I used to
do that once I heard that I was like
okay I'll just get up before everyone
and and work and I'm a morning person so
I can do that it's a bit
interesting oh because you have to work
out your sleep schedule but and people
judge you for going to bed at 7:00 at
night sometimes but I'm okay with that
you know you got to do what you got to
do
you